[Music]
how much of civilization is shaped by
our biology
how might our cities transportation and
technology look different if we weren't
a group of nearly hairless primates
the video game spore has the answers
okay well maybe not the answers but
spore does offer an interesting case
study into the fundamentals of how a
speculative life form might build a
society
in our first war episode we followed a
life form from a microscopic organism to
the intelligent curiosis sapiens
in this episode we'll witness the ascent
of their civilization and explore how
the unique biology of an alien like
curiosis sapiens would affect things
like the design of clothing the
schematics of vehicles and the shapes of
buildings in unexpected ways we'll begin
with tribal stage and go all the way to
space completing the multi-billion year
tale of curiosis sapiens
so let's return to planet curious and
discover the finale of the story of life
after the early evolutionary stages the
birth of society is underway with
curiosis sapiens building fires in early
lodgings
but is this the dawn of a wise people or
a culture of warmongering tyrants what
path will curiosis sapiens take in
shaping the destiny of their planet
like the game's biology cultural
evolution and spore is fairly simplified
and exaggerated tribal stage seems to be
a mesh of various eras but seems most
comparable to a hunter-gatherer culture
at this point in history curiosis
sapiens appear to only have access to
simple technologies quite similar to
that of early humans
it might seem surprising that
curiosities would converge on concepts
like pottery but there is some precedent
for this idea
on earth certain technologies are
cultural universals meaning that
numerous cultures invented a version of
them independently from one another the
sheer number of times disparate
populations have invented something like
pottery indicates that when intelligent
minds are faced with the same problem
similar answers might emerge whether or
not this would hold true for an alien in
an alien environment is difficult to say
but depending on the circumstances
curiosis sapiens inventing pottery is
certainly possible
as technology improves spore gives us
the option to determine the clothing of
curiosity sapiens the question of what
kind of clothes an emerging sapient
alien species would wear assuming they'd
wear clothing at all is actually a
tricky one clothing is so ubiquitous
today for us homo sapiens that we almost
don't think about it the initial
invention of clothing was likely tied to
climate and served as a way to protect
our hairless bodies from the elements
yet compared to earth planet curious
like most planets in spore seems to have
an extremely temperate macro climate so
it's unlikely clothing would develop
from temperature control alone yet
clothing can also protect the body from
specific environmental hazards like
pests abrasive substances and other
irritants so it's possible that
protective attire would first emerge in
curiosis sapiens in particularly
vulnerable areas like the base of their
eyestalks
human clothing also has various social
functions across cultures and some
articles of alien clothing could serve
in these ways unlike humans curiosis
sapiens have an elaborate display
structure sprouting from their shoulders
similar to the extravagant plumages of
certain birds it's not too big a leap to
assume garments would be built around
complementing these structures making
them appear fuller and more impressive
an emergent hunter-gatherer species
would also likely find value in various
satchels or pouches to carry resources
and finally aliens might develop some
articles of clothing with no apparent
function whatsoever either as
reflections of cultural trends or
expressions of personal style
in the case of curiosities clothing
choices would be limited by available
materials which in this age would likely
comprise hides grass leaves and shells
the end result is a tire that certainly
looks pretty strange to our eyes but a
curiosity sapiens would likely find the
eccentricities of our clothing just as
puzzling
as time passes curiosis sapiens fall
into a rhythm within the hunter-gatherer
lifestyle with obtaining food the most
important task during this era
historically permanent settlements on
earth rarely emerge until after the
invention of agriculture and
domesticated plants spore skips over any
mention of agriculture but realistically
we can assume that curiosities have some
early version of subsistence farming
figured out in curiosis sapiens aren't
the only life forms to have achieved
advanced intelligence across planet
curious other species are building their
own societies different unrelated
species reaching the same level of
technological advancement during the
exact same period isn't particularly
likely but this is how spore functions
the question is how will curiosis
sapiens choose to interact with their
new neighbors going forwards
to guide curiosis sapiens through this
new era two tools are now available for
construction the spear and the wooden
horn which looks like a kind of
rudimentary flute as far as early tools
go these are actually fairly plausible
spears are the oldest weapon we have an
unambiguous archaeological record of
dating back to the paleolithic age
likewise mammoth bone flutes from the
paleolithic are the oldest known musical
instruments realistically however the
tools of a species like curiosis sapiens
would likely be different from our own
for one since curiosis sapiens only have
four fingers instead of five their
musical instruments would likely look
different as they'd probably only have
access to a pentatonic scale instead of
a heptatonic one when playing a wind
instrument with five notes per octave
instead of seven
likewise it's interesting to deliberate
on whether a life form like curiosis
sapiens would develop a spear in the
first place humans lack the claws and
fangs of most top predators in the
animal kingdom pressuring early humans
to invent tools to compete with the
natural weaponry of other animals yet an
unarmed curiosity sapiens is already a
formidable customer and might not need
to be as creative
still it's possible that any emergent
tool user would be able to puzzle out
the basic concept that sticking
something sharp on the end of something
long is a good way to deal damage while
keeping yourself out of harm's reach in
either case with their new tools
curiosis sapiens can now enchant other
species with their musical instruments
or impale them on the end of their spear
as thinking social omnivores curiosis
sapiens make allies when they can but
when another species attacks first
curiosis sapiens respond in kind in a
trend that sadly echoes our own history
this early era is marked by frequent
conflict
but society is also changing in other
ways curiosity sapiens are on the path
towards creating a larger and more
stable civilization a path laden with
new developments at this point curiosity
sapiens gain the ability to domesticate
animals a crucial trait for emergent
civilizations there's a lot that could
be said about animal domestication but
to simplify we humans began our animal
domestication journey with wolves before
the agricultural revolution then moved
on to small herbivores like sheep and
goats once we began staying in one place
for longer beasts of burden that could
plow fields or give you a ride like cows
and horses came later curiosis sapiens
will begin their journey with this small
bird-like quadruped harvesting their
feathers for clothing and construction
materials in their eggs for dietary
consumption generations later the second
animal curiosis sapiens domesticate is
this large horrifying spider beast these
hearty giants might look intimidating
but they're actually quite docile and
will fill the role of plow animals it's
worth noting that while once again spore
never touches on agriculture in order
for this sort of domestication to be
possible curioso sapiens must have begun
the practice and with these animals in
their corner the population can grow to
new sizes and society itself can become
more complex
new buildings are now available like
this outlet for fishing spears
seemingly implying the emergence of
small industries and the increased
specialization of tasks within curiosa
sapiens society and just looking at
their society culture seems richer and
more diverse with different curiosity
sapiens sharing ideas and playing
musical instruments after making one
final alliance spore gives us the option
to advance to the next stage
hurtling forwards in time civilization
stage begins with the option to build a
modern building once again spore's
timeline of historical change is
certainly a simplified one as there are
historically numerous steps between
small subsistence societies in an
emergent industrial civilization
likewise spore puts no limits on this
first building letting you construct
something truly absurd if you feel like
it fun as that can be it's interesting
to consider what an early industrial
house might look like for curiosis
sapiens unlike humans curiosis sapiens
are nest builders and have been for the
past several hundred million years of
their evolution as a result it's
possible that their instincts for houses
would be different from our own building
smaller more low to the ground dwellings
that evoke their ancestral nests
with a town hall constructed the
curiosity sapiens debate the nature of
their society
with a stable food supply natural
resources like spice which flows from
most planets in spore becomes the new
valued commodity the value of spice and
spore reminds me of the sci-fi world
dune and if my memory of that series is
accurate a reliance on spice might cause
problems but for now curios's sapiens
are a young populace with their heads
lost in the dream of the future
on that note spore gives us the option
to design our first vehicle that will
help with transporting the spice as
always spore lets you design whatever
absurd thing you want but alien cars
genuinely might not look like what we'd
expect
certain things like wheels could be
universal considering the constraints of
physics yet our vehicles reflect us more
than we realize
several studies have shown that when we
look at most cars our brain's facial
recognition cortex is activated this
isn't a coincidence cars are designed to
subtly resemble human faces to appeal to
our pattern-seeking minds and if
curiosis sapiens have similar instincts
it's likely their vehicles would subtly
reflect the geometry of their faces
with the first vehicle constructed the
spice can be gathered and transported
for better or worse in this era other
civilizations of curiosities have also
emerged we've already seen this species
much like humans has the potential for
war and cooperation so the ultimate
future of planet curious will be
determined by how well they can work
together contacting our closest
neighbors we can offer gifts compliment
them or say their people are descended
from limless space slugs now i'm no
political expert but i suspect one of
the first two options is a better tactic
thanks to such savvy political acumen
the two civilizations establish a trade
route and begin the long road towards a
united future as time passes cities
become larger and full of new
technologies thanks to the steady force
of negotiation alliances form first with
immediate neighbors and then with more
distant countries as technology improves
clothing evolves as well featuring new
textiles and construction materials i
tried to make the post-industrial
clothes of curiosis sapiens still
vaguely echo earlier cultural trends got
to keep those silly hats after all
in time we unlock the secrets of
motorized flying machines and can design
our first air vehicles here the
constraints of things like wind
resistance might shape our craft into
something similar to the planes we have
on earth although just like with their
land vehicles curiosis sapiens may build
something that subtly reflects the
geometry of their faces and with their
natural stock eyes and more flexible
necks curiosity sapiens likely have a
greater visual field than humans so the
cockpits of their aircrafts might have
more windows to the sides and back
with aircrafts now soaring through the
atmosphere the planet is more connected
through trade than ever before achieving
planetary peace through careful
management and negotiation is admittedly
not the most exciting but it's certainly
worth it
at the end of this era
sapiens are united under one banner and
looking towards the stars as their next
horizon
and so the final chapter space stage
begins curiosis sapiens are no longer
beholden to just a single meager world
after designing a spacecraft that
follows the same aesthetic standards of
other vehicles for the first time
curiosis sapiens are free to explore
beyond the protective atmosphere of
their home
traveling to another planet in the
system the sapiens discover a crash
vessel and are lucky enough to scan and
replicate its interstellar drive
from the perspective of the player you
can now zoom out and behold the entire
galaxy spinning just like how it is in
the title screen except you can now go
to any part of it you like that first
moment when you realize the whole galaxy
is now yours to explore is pretty
magical and makes the scope of spore
feel so impossibly vast the galaxy is
waiting and the rest is up to you
every one of these stars contains their
own system of orbiting planets which you
can fly down to and visit at the time
when spore first came out this kind of
procedurally generated universe was
something never really attempted before
at the same time such scale has its
drawbacks it's hard not to feel like in
a galaxy this large nothing you do has
much meaning i know a lot of people's
least favorite stage is space stage and
i understand why it's easy to become
disconnected from the creature you
started with billions of years ago
although perhaps that's an unavoidable
symptom of a species becoming a galaxy
spanning civilization
expanding across the cosmos curiosis
sapiens gain the ability to build
self-assembling colonies on barren
worlds in their expansion they search
for radio wave frequencies that might
signal the presence of technologically
advanced life like themselves on our
planet we're scanning the stars for
alien life by searching for similar
frequencies although with our limited
range so far we've found nothing but
silence yet curiosity sapiens can
journey much further out across the
stars and eventually they encounter
other intelligent space-faring life who
rose from the primordial soup just like
they did in time curios's sapiens even
unlock the secrets of life and can
create creatures to populate newly
terraformed worlds this kind of power
can be used to create bizarre forms of
life as biology becomes an infinite
playground in the words of science
fiction author arthur c clarke any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and that
adage holds true here it can also be
used more responsibly and we'd have to
hope that such an advanced form of life
would be sensible with their power
looking forwards curiosis sapiens will
ascend to a civilization we can't fathom
transcending technology beyond the scope
of our limited minds
by design spore skips over many of the
stages of history condensing and
exaggerating the long road of
technological advancement yet the game
does explore a surprising number of the
universal principles of how
civilizations and technology change over
time i know not everybody likes the
later stages of spore compared to cell
and creature and i can understand that
still the novelty of guiding a
speculative creature through their
technological advancement is still
pretty intriguing even all these years
later like i said in part 1 i'd love to
see another high profile game tackle
something similar as i feel there's real
potential for a modern take on this
concept
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support to help make videos like this
possible by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
i